He or she who cares the least or he or she who appears to care the least or seems or
appears to seem like they're the most willing to walk away is the person that has control.
And if you're out of control in a deal, you're not going to get the deal.
And so if you're sitting there right now and you have a deal where someone's going to call
you back, it's time for the pullback.
If you're sitting there right now with a business owner who's not answering your calls, it's
time for the pullback.
If you're sitting there in a relationship and you have zero control, it's time to be
willing to walk.
OK, the person he or she who cares the least or appears to care the least has the control.
OK, and this game is about doing deals.
And when you want to if you want to get deals, you need to have control.
OK, that's it.
That's the pullback.